when you're on Tick Tock is it like do
you notice the algorithm trying to feed
you things to get you to go down
different paths oh yeah absolutely and
the problem is that when you're in
Social settings after you like watch
Tick Tock so much and you're so addicted
like you're always looking for like that
quick hit of dopamine and you're not
getting it in normal social settings
like you would on Tick Tock so you're
always like I'm so bored and like I've
cut myself off it's horrible and it
happens to a lot of people I'm pretty
sure like girls were getting like ticks
from Tick Tock they were literally that
was a big story they started twitching
because they because the algorithm would
feed them videos of women with
Tourette's and then they would watch
these videos endlessly a woman ticking
and then they would start developing
ticks this is the crazy thing when I saw
a story like that I was like maybe maybe
women are more susceptible to social
engineering than men I mean I think I
shouldn't say maybe I think it's
factually true so the fact that women
can generate a fake Social Tourette's
says a lot about what social media is
doing to the fabric of society